live
live it
holy moly small hey guys
what's up how are you
how are you surviving this heat let me
move you a little a little further away
don't want you caught that close that's
weird
this is a good shot all right we'll keep
it like that then am i playing full guys
or is this bait why would i
bait you guys huh do i look like a
baiter
i'm a masturbator oh no
oh god
i forgot my headphones so i'm wearing
my wireless ones very chic
very cool i bet you a bunch of streamers
have like
big cringy gaming headphones
chad wears in-air wireless
headphones that's how it's done
i'm playing on my laptop and my
computer's
burning up how's the audio is it okay it
will not be perfect i cannot be [ __ ]
it's already like what is even i'm
wearing these what is this
what is this the microphone should be
better
see i keep forgetting like different
stuff and different setups
i could buy two of the same but that's
i don't know i don't do that
i don't do that i just don't
jack said he's down to play so i'll play
with the the irish
i wrote him ready whenever so i assume
that means that we are just good to like
play it one without him
i think that's the rules right if he if
jaka boy don't uh
say nothing then pewdiepie is gonna go
ain't got time to wait for the irish
think about the world how it would be if
you waited for the irish
not opposite of good
yeah all right you guys ready for some
win
i'm actually kind of pro at this game i
haven't told anyone about it
but i'm already level seven
yeah and i have the dinosaur outfit
that's pretty cool thank you
and how
[Music]
how high is this game isn't too too high
for your motherfloppers
i think the best i've gone is like four
hey nice clock where you can see my
clock
clocker yeah
um all right let's skull i heard this
game is pretty good like people like it
and uh i just want to
show you guys that this game is not good
and everyone who likes it is wrong
hey shut up this game is great shut up
man all right
all right we'll watch watch a pro do it
first try
first try let's go first try get the
[ __ ] out of my way
what they're all doing my same strategy
uh if i fail like that it's because uh
science and reasons [ __ ]
god god i hope i win guys
i'll go for the middle go mid go mid go
mid yeah
if i don't qualify there needs to be a
punishment you guys
what do you wanna oh god it's fine
what should the punishment be delete
youtube channel okay i'm in
i'm in
yeah all right guess i don't have to
delete my channel guys
am i winning absolutely first try
imagine failing chi
shun shan glory to hk thank you thank
you
[Music]
200 000 push-ups if i fail
all right easy
that's my camera in the way well excuse
me so much
is it better there
ready 50 50 punishment oh god no i ain't
doing that
[ __ ] that yeah this is god of war
new uh texture pack i can't do this one
all right give me tips on this one
because i never qualified on this
i don't understand
i was gonna i was gonna stream god of
war but i of course forgot a cable again
so i can't [ __ ] plug in my
playstation
is this not moving oh this is trippy
is it not moving this is moving very
slowly
seven is eliminated already don't push
me
they're playing dirty
this is so slow isn't it oh god i have
to go here otherwise i die
13 eliminated don't fall off
this is so easy how do i ever fail at
this
[Music]
this is like a kids game
i've been seeing people rage at this
game bunch of actual children
how do you feel at this am i winning yes
then look how easy this game is
oh wow that was so difficult
push him that's just rude rude
how do i push
four people fail cringe
you're bad you're bird
[Music]
did i see doc playing it unfortunately i
missed that
i'm really glad that's the game he
played on his return
[Music]
all right is this the memory one i never
played this one i've only seen it online
so i match the icons alright help me out
guys honestly
uh our apple apple melon
what am i supposed to do
stand on what it says sir all right
i'm on an apple right yeah i'm pretty
sure i'm an apple
okay banana grape melon
and also banana there banana great melon
easy
you have to be it you have to be a
chimpanzee not be able to do this
actually they have great memories banana
grape melon
all right melon oh i don't know where
okay here's the melon
tricked you
no it didn't work okay uh
wait what grape banana
uh what are those cherries great banana
cherry
is there anything else apple in the
corner over there
great banana cherry cherry is here
whoa all right
i guess my brain just is too big for
this game
this is god of war guys this is
how easy is one little [ __ ]
wow just wow
follow the crowd you sheep no i don't do
that [ __ ]
all right so which one is this
okay this is the one where you have to
find the road right
this is where you don't follow the sheep
all right i'm just gonna follow everyone
all right here we go
he pushed me that's illegal
oh you can jump across there that's
[Applause]
funny
um
guess that's the way
i'm just gonna be chill this is the
threat
i'm happy to chill at the end no problem
you're a big guy
is this a strat don't [ __ ] touch me
the [ __ ] touch me
don't [ __ ] touch me
don't stop touching me
they're touching me
it's got to be there oh god oh god
no no no
no why he went so fast what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] damn i'm sorry
oh god ready 50 50.
[ __ ] shout out to a man that going
through chemo shout out to him
damn stay strong that was not the right
energy in reading that jesus
[ __ ]
all right next wait no i don't see other
[ __ ] people play
what is this get the [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out get that zero deaths
that did not
count that does not count whatsoever
i'm gonna give you guys a check and then
there just wait just wait
just give me five minutes five
minutes
do you understand zero deaths we won
how many times have we won so far i lost
count um all right here we go
let's go again if any one of you all
[ __ ] streams like me
i will find where you live just so you
know if you find where i
live in game i find where you live in
life
let's [ __ ] go 100k watching let's get
this dinner
100k people got nothing better to do
i'll serve you this dinner i'll show you
how it's done
you're watching the one and only the
best gamer on the planet
i've only played this game once okay
maybe twice
all right here we go here we go this is
the easy one uh i guarantee you if i
don't do this one
i will i what should i do something
really bad
something a really bad chat
i need something real bad see i start at
the edge
i have to say a word bad enough to get
me banned on stream
okay i'll do that that's how confident i
am
that's how com
that's how confident i am in this
that's how i'm confident i feel about
this
i am lagging
god i'm being pushed around all right
mid mid mid mid mid for sure
no push it [ __ ]
commit commit commit don't [ __ ] legal
me
simps all right bad word bad word watch
out
bad word bad word oh god oh god that's
not 45 is it
okay go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go
go go go go go go go oh god
there will be no stream ban tonight boys
that's what i'm talking about
the stakes are high the stakes are high
but it's worth it
because i'm confident in my skills i
know what i'm doing
let's get this dinner let's get this
dinner
that was not close that's called
suspense something that
you guys that don't know what it's like
to entertain know anything about
okay i don't know why i'm so mean to you
guys thank you for being i appreciate
you sorry
if i lose i have to buy 100 jake paul
merch oh that hurts
that actually hurts i don't want to give
money to that guy
this is the easiest one of all time
i kind of want to take you up on it but
i also really
really don't want to buy jake paul merch
[ __ ] stop [ __ ] touching me stop
[ __ ] touching me
stop touching me mom he's touching me
this this [ __ ] pineapple [ __ ] knows
who i am [ __ ] off pineapple
stop you're super annoying and i don't
like you
stop
god stop just stop you're super annoying
no one likes you you have no friends
[Laughter]
eat ass pineapple [ __ ] off
to stream snipe me you get you get the
[ __ ]
jake paul merch 100 let's go
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
under jake paul merch if i fail let's go
i ain't gonna fail though sorry jake
paul
sorry to rob you from your month revenue
from your yearly
revenue source of people buying your
merch
out of god damn pity i'd have got a
self-risk
oh god oh god all right got a goddamn
self-restraint
how long does this keep going
holy moly molly polly
no we're punishments no more punishments
i don't want to do it i don't want to do
it i'm not i'm not i'm out
i'm out i'm out i ain't doing it again
i'm not doing that ever again [ __ ]
that
[Music]
god damn that was some high stakes
don't need to punish
[Music]
why do you think it's pre-recorded shut
the [ __ ] up blah blah you get banned
why because i'm epic at the game i'm the
epic at all games
blah blah now you have to buy a hundred
jake paul merch
or write an apology what the [ __ ] is
this map
oh god it's the fruits what's the strat
on the fruits oh god i'm not supposed to
jump up i remember that that's that's
something i remember
you just got to walk across i never
actually qualified oh for [ __ ] sake
yeah i'm done all right cool i'm
actually last
all right here we go i got it
i got it i got it
get the [ __ ] out of my all that orange
is gonna be
i got it i got it i got it
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i got it i got it
well there's no i god damn it
i'm sorry i'm sorry
oh blooper is calling me that's perfect
timing
hello what's up are you winning son
oh yes
that doesn't sound like you won no it
doesn't matter well
i had some epic clutches so it's
something
that's good did you push anyone off say
hi to stream
uh yeah i accidentally pushed someone
off they tried to push me up
hey hey stream stream stream stream
all right dinner dinner chicken splinter
let's get it join my party bro get
it let's get it i'm i'm logging in
let's i gotta log into
hold up
fall guys epic fall guys yeah pretty
epic
the hell is your icon
why would you why would you do that
because i like it don't ever do that
again
okay all right
all right we doing punishments or not
uh sure why not yeah all right chad give
us some punishment
we had a hundred hundred jake paul merch
oh god saying never mind
dude i was so close i'm going down
all right kiss all right what's your
enemy you have the bell that you love do
you have an enemy
uh you all right well then you have to
kiss me ew
exactly i'm never losing i have to kiss
the ceiling
oh gross can i reach it
shut yeah of course i can of course i
can reach the seedling jack what do you
think i'm
what were you insinuating
can i reach the ceiling of course i can
reach the ceiling
why do i hear the game twice where's the
audio just that annoying
i have no idea okay tactic for this one
okay immediately is that really
attacking
yeah you'll come out on top i promise
you
right all right all right i'm trusting
you i'm on the yeah i'm right next to
you dude
oh hell yeah
oh you slide holy moly yeah bro
irish tricks i'm winning i'm winning
push me push me back baby push me push
me
oh oh oh okay okay okay okay okay okay
front pack mid mid mid mid mid [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] i guess over it hell yeah
first baby [ __ ] you irish sorry i mean
that's good for you i'm team same team
same team same team oh [ __ ]
what happened i got hit by the ball i've
never been hit by the balls on this
level
no luck of the irish huh no
you're not a big guy huh goddammit
qualify you're not a big guy huh
oh felix chad can you hear jack all
right by the way oh my god i'm out
i'm out no really for real on the first
one yeah
well i haven't ever ever lost that
we're leaving solitude everyone silent
moment for jack
guess we have to kiss now bro that's all
right
silent bell let's take it that was just
practice chat
that was his practice just a warm up is
jack chicken
yes god
see how much better i am than you no
offense
all right how many wins do you have
how many wins do i have yeah
is that a question yeah so how many wins
do i have
yeah you're asking me how many wins i
have
so yeah you're asking me how many wins
do i
have yeah you're asking me
okay i have one win so i don't know what
i'm talking about yeah
it was on playstation so it doesn't
count really
yeah playstation's easier how do you
fail on this one
i don't know get hit by [ __ ] balls
don't get hit by balls bro
try not to it wasn't my fault it was the
ball's fault oh yeah you're right
oh my god too many people let me through
all right you never get the first one
you just gotta commit to a second one
and then you go on the sides that's the
trick
they've told me about that last time
when i got hit yeah but you still gotta
dodge the balls
it doesn't make you invulnerable it's
crazy yeah it does
oh i'm gonna win i'm gonna win this one
nice
did i no i didn't i got second [ __ ]
cringe
holy moly cringe
not even first not first cringe
round over we will stop by let's go
you mean let's go let's go baby
if i win i am going to shave my
what's up gamers this is fall guys
whoever doesn't win
has to feed a cow their foot oh
thousand dollars to everyone watching
the stream keep watching it's real
whoever wins this round gets a hundred
million dollars
100 million in monopoly money what was
that
nothing oh dude i haven't played this
one i haven't played this either one
time
wait i have played this don't we played
it once
all right we have no idea what we were
doing it's tag but you can keep tagging
people
yeah oh god there was one on our side
are you kidding
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna chill
raider
he was behind enemy lines pro strats pro
strikes
okay i got one they're trying not to get
jinxed but i'm the jinx master baby
come here i'm playing i'm playing the
then end game
good good stay away too many stinkies
come here come here watch out we're
actually losing so i probably should
oh baby i'm on the wheel i'm jinxing all
of them
oh really yeah
i got like five what the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] touched me
oh oh there's one on the wheel
jack really disgusting oh god it's close
dude uh
[ __ ] oh no oh god it's so close i'm
getting all of them oh no we're gonna
lose we're gonna lose
no no no no no no no no no oh
jack what oh there he is he was on top
of it the wheel
the wheel is a strand clearly i should
have done that yeah
[ __ ] all right leave leave leave no one
sees cringe
cringe cringe all right guys i guess we
own you guys
a thousand dollars just like post your
credit card information in the chat
that's a joke by the way don't blame me
that's a joke
can never be too sure in these days yeah
i wish all of chat would die that's just
a joke it's just a joke
the [ __ ] dude don't ban me come on
don't bend me they just i didn't
go on reddit and be like man i just made
a joke
and youtube took it out of context and
banned me it was crazy
crazy
[Laughter]
what's your shipping address give me
your p.o box
give me your blood type give me what's
your mother's maiden name
what was your first pet what street did
you grow up on
okay what's the strategy for this i i
suck at this one
uh oh god no just don't jump across them
that's
tactic okay no bangles
walls your gamer tag
okay what's up gain stop won't stop
oh god oh god i might have to stop
qualify
the trick is to not get greedy you know
what i'm seeing yeah i'm saying
i should not have jumped there get on
your feet soldier [ __ ]
on your face soldier
nice okay can you guys bring it back
down over this side thank you
thank you on your feet soldier [ __ ]
there's a water fight oh
oh oh can you guys stop being greedy
oh oh my god oh my god
go
dude i'm about to win he's one shot he's
one shot
[Laughter]
my brain just froze for a second that
was great
don't be greedy don't be greedy don't be
greedy you son of [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] on behalf of the
youtubers let us win
yeah we're not you're not making content
we're not important
oh my god oh my god dude dude
dude dude you're not gonna believe this
dude
oh for [ __ ] sake [ __ ] god damn it
dude dude i'm going over oh my god
you're trash dude
okay one more one more one more come on
come on oh my god get the pink going oh
my god what are you doing
[ __ ] it's like the titanic sinking over
here oh look at me don't look at me
cool head you gotta have a cool head you
gotta train all of these guys
dumb head no your feet
i'm not having a very cool head right
now
i'm not winning oh dad don't look at me
oh please dad oh i'm [ __ ] i'm through
i'm thrilled dad i'm a
degenerate dad dad
i'm a dude i watch hentai i'm sorry dad
oh chad move oh no are you out he's
touching me
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this was that the first
one
yeah sucks bro leave cringe
judge why are we so annoying together
we were i was
[ __ ] playing me for you being [ __ ]
all right good come on another one we
gotta win they're hungry another one
they're hungry in the chat they want
wins
why would you jump into one that's
almost upside down
scalare don't ever question me playing
again that's like asking a pro player
why you are inferior it's like asking
ninja if he can stop thinking about time
travel come on bro
he's not gonna do that do you know what
i'm doing it's just not possible
it's not possible it's in the back of
his head 24
7. does ninja play fall guys
i hope so i'm playing as a ninja
character tweet ninja right now
that you're tweeting ninja character
please ninja
ninja please let's come back to youtube
stream tweet item stream stream
stream stream on youtube all right
this one's easy if you lose at this one
you shouldn't have been born just
realized that here
i wait what the [ __ ] did you say nothing
i'm winning dead bed
tell me your [ __ ] dad i will leave
your ass so quick
[ __ ] i'm gonna stream tonight i'm
getting stream stuff
dude dude i'm getting stream dude
that's terrible oh let me oh i was on
top of it
you said you said you weren't supposed
to be born
all right so how does this work oh my
god people keep knocking me into it
no come on all right all right all right
it's pure luck it's pure luck it's pure
luck it's pure luck it's pure luck
yes it's pierced right there i'm right
there i'm right there
i'm right there bro are you in are you
bro are you in bro
all i see is you bro all i see is you
bro i closed my eyes and all i see
all this is that w i i guess i guess we
deserve to be bored
i guess that's that's what mean that's
what i was trying to motivate you
positive reinforcement
it worked you should feed me cracker
next time i do even better
the future don't feed me crack next time
yes just give me a small crack pipe
start with crack and then
work your way to crack oh not the [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right what's the tactic come on
it's too greedy it's you have to be
either first or nowhere
um we're starting the last line cringe
james just does not want us to have fun
does it
i'm already off i should not get your
feet so
ah it's okay
we're we're at an advantage now why
because everybody else is going to try
and do this [ __ ] together and it's not
going to work
and we get the opposite side of where
everybody's falling off
damn you're i don't know what i don't
know what i'm saying you're smarter than
a lot of people bro you're smarter than
you
look oh god run my fellows
yes get out of my way pineapple
what kind of fruit are you a pineapple
cringe
trash
all right i'm on the last one where are
you are you winning
i'm on the one before the last one stop
being greedy i'm
helping other people over here for
[ __ ] sake come over here dumbasses
god sometimes i just jump and my guy
decides to do a backflip
oh god oh god i'm so late dude
this is cringe i'm posting cringe right
now
oh i'm posting i'm going to revoke your
gamer card
no no no no no no no no no no no
i saw that i saw that that's cringe
that's cringe
laugh at me oh i shouldn't have jumped
but it worked
oh i'm gonna make it for everyone we're
gonna make it bro
so greedy i can't move anywhere
we're going to make it bro we're going
to make it bro
we're going to make it bro i wait for
you bro i see you bro please i see you
bro i open my eyes bro
i look at you bro i'm here bro don't
[ __ ] come near me
oh god okay i shouldn't have jumped i
shouldn't have jumped i i
bro bro cool hand i'm a cool head i'm a
cool hand
out cool bro cool head cool head bro bro
cool head bro
cool ahead grab everybody grab grab
everybody at the end i'm grabbing them
bro
bro i gotta go on without you bro please
play it on bro i believe in you
i gotta believe in me bro i hate see-saw
it's the worst
watch your beating scramble next
you hate vsauce dude
yeah oh
oh you got this you got this
uh this is easy bro you got this a win
for
one is a win for all
yeah we played this just you and me like
offline and it's like oh cool
that's fun going straight people
watching now
bro youtuber i can't even control it
either i think i'm just
yeah i don't know oh they're dude
they're pushing me what the hell
dude they're pushing me dude
are you there triceratops on the blue
yeah
try star thoughts yeah they know it they
know it's you
for sure because they're scared of me
which they should
be they should be don't push me
look at this guy look at this dude this
dude look at this dude trying to push me
you're good you're good you're good i'm
good i'm good am i good though
yeah are you are you good bro oh my
goodness dude whenever you play this on
playstation people go out immediately
for some reason
yeah i don't even know why kids play
playstation real gamers play uh
xbox no wait uh check out that check
check out the jawline jawline check
jawline check
what is that because you're a chad
oh yeah yeah of course a pc true
god the music is annoying nice it's
trying to throw you off
don't let it oh no one can throw me up
bro
chad chad chad get it left chad
oh god i was gonna go there damn that
was close
two more one more one more it ain't
gonna be me
ain't gonna be me oh you're good yeah
all right we get it this is a win i can
smell it it smells toasty
oh you got two more rounds though what's
the next one going to be oh no
no problem dude it's going to be
rocket league for sure all right there's
rocket league
pc masteries am i right guys
cringe am i hearing the game through
your microphone i'm so confused
like i hear the game audio twice it's
super [ __ ] annoying
everyone's complaining and chance i'm
sure it's fine this is annoying do you
hear it
do you hear it twice now yeah
it's it ain't you okay oh it's rocket
league
all right that's right what's the strat
uh somebody has to stay goalie okay you
got goalies you're good
all right offense offense
i played this last night and i won 15-0
because people just gave up nice no
no do not delete this nice uh we're all
goalkeepers
they can never score
they they only have one goalkeeper so
get the ball down there and you're good
and then get ready for kickoff here we
go here we go
two nothing wrong with me three
yeah here we go here we go here we go
now
yes cringe also why do you keep making
dark knight rises reference
you're a big guy so fun to say [ __ ] it
yes yes get it blue
i shouldn't have that blue
oh they're playing only playing itself
go shelf goal
so cool
i'll get the kickoff [ __ ] he got an epic
kick off
[Music]
who [ __ ] that kicked off all right i
got the kick off i got the kick up
no
i wonder if your hitbox is bigger my
hitbox is bigger
my biggest hitbox you've ever seen [ __ ]
yeah you're right
you know what you're right there you go
there you go there you go chase it chase
have it taste it oh chase it taste it
center senator
yeah i'm not doing anything
i hate it dad i'm winning
oh they almost scored oh dave dave dude
dixon
come on come on there you go there you
go keep it in the air
oh keep it going oh they scored twice
why are you not telling me
oh [ __ ] they did my goalkeepers suck
suck you don't even have one anymore
[ __ ] i shot it in
oh your goalkeeper
where's the chat where's the chat
i'm done i'm
i don't have time to play games i have
to play more games
wait i gotta restart the game it's so
annoying i'm hearing the audio twice and
it makes me wanna
not do anything okay yeah
okay do it all right the dinner is
coming up
this next one i have a strong sense of
responsibility
we were close you were close
i was picking my nose back in the
sidelines we're a team bro
do you mean it yeah
of course okay i need an epic outfit
all right let's see if i can fix the
stupid auto issue
i didn't rage quit it's called a
tactical quit
tactical bailout tactical bailout bro
never heard of it
[Music]
okay i'm inviting you no you need to
invite me
okay it was 4-1 it was close
done it honestly could have been
anyone's game who knows i left so
i would never know yeah you can't lose
if you don't
see who wins you laugh you lose if you
die
wait what
that's a fan suggestion for sure
yeah yeah that's about the
as good as it gets this guy it's uh
jose or jose he's been asking for your
life you lose for like four weeks
jose not happening bro it's not
happening dude
forget about it just pry yourself to
sleep
oh it's like i haven't laughed in so
long
i keep losing i keep losing
someone donated 400 seriously am i
getting troll
i'll read it a second will you play god
of war again felix
felix boy boy
do you get it
boy i got it i got that one actually i
made it got a chocolate here oh
[ __ ] god greedy greedy greedy greedy
everyone's so greedy
greedy queen
we're just annoying in general it's not
because we're youtubers
yeah i was the last one on that [ __ ] oh
i'm ahead now it's so much easier
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm way behind
give me a [ __ ] beta i call you
[ __ ] bad all i want beta
you better believe it
i'm being their beta about helping them
go up because they're greedy god [ __ ]
i hate you guys honestly [ __ ] beta
behavior over here there it is
this mode is just bangles bro there it
is i'm on the last one bro
i'm on the last one bro this is it
thanks for sticking with my then i think
all right here we go this is this is the
worst i
hate i really i realize what you got to
do is you got trick people that you want
to cooperate
in reality just [ __ ] go for it and
say [ __ ] you
honestly it's like stupid you guys want
to be friends haha [ __ ] you
you think you can like coordinate
something and then
no you can't it's like hey we can all
work together
i'm holding people for you bro [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
yeah [ __ ] you oh god everyone's jumping
on this one now
no no no don't do it oh no where are you
do it you're on the last one don't do it
hey i'm on the last one but everyone's
being annoying
yeah you ain't going nowhere you
understand you understand you're not
going anywhere you're not
oh yeah oh yeah you know anything oh
yeah oh bro i might be
i'm i'm through bro i'm through bro go
go go go make it bro
we're in when make make it bro chad chad
chad chad chad chad
i feel like saying you're a chat is the
most is the least chad
it's the most chat it's the most chat
because you're confident in yourself
oh i see i see
it was 400 indian dollars okay and i'll
read it later
cringe uh you know if it's an epic
donation when the
color changes yeah
some people don't even super chat
how do you know we're not referencing
chad the country in africa
then it's still chad yeah
cringe all right
this is child's play this one is so easy
if you fail on this you might as well
just install uninstall
uninstall okay we're all running the
same tile what's up bro
oh hell yeah bruh all right great okay
orange
all right grape orange easy easy easy
okay i stay on orange for now pushing me
off though they're dude they're pushing
me
yeah which one is it which one is it
it's not yet we haven't seen it yet
[ __ ] pushing it's orange come
here come here
don't let them don't let them it's super
annoying stop it
stop all right what are we going banana
banana
okay grape cherry cherry apple banana
down here no no no no no
banana grape cherry don't change it okay
just keep it in your head stop saying
things okay okay
oh [ __ ] off here here here here here oh
okay
oh god oh people actually failed cringe
courage all right so what do we got
uh apple apple watermelon banana
oh lord okay you you have
have them yeah i have these ones okay
cherry watermelon grape
please be one of those all right
see here okay this is so much nicer when
i have a friend to play with
and why because then we only have to
remember half of them each
how's your memory bro terrible
[ __ ] ape brain there's six things to
remember there
really yeah oh no
all the fruits yeah oh
yeah you just get lucky bro
no i knew there were six it's five or
six
jesus what we got what we got oh team
tail tag easy
easy the tactic here
is to not let your tail get taken
okay i appreciate that thank you for
that little tip there bruh
[ __ ] idiot [ __ ] you [ __ ] oh sorry is
i not muted oh
am i
yeah okay i'm gonna stay on the conveyor
and go against it because two people
with tails
give me tail give me tail oh you got so
many tails down here
yeah oh come here red come here ready
oh come on how am i not grabbing any of
these i'm like right on them okay i got
a tail
later bro later bro i'm staying in the
middle
i'm staying in the middle mid strat mid
lane strength
dude no one's coming through the middle
this is epic [ __ ] i landed on
your [ __ ] ass licking [ __ ]
he goes live and he just starts swearing
again like that
oh mercedes thank you hey god damn he
took that
like [ __ ] force pulled that off my
ass yeah right
[ __ ] lag come here why can't i lag
and grab it
lag and grab bro give me that tail boy
give me that tail boy ow
one more minute i can't wait that long
yeah two minutes is agony in this game
my tail got stolen i'm not a big guy
i'm stupid i'm stopping i stole from
teammate
at least you have a tail i got a tail
it's all good
i'm sorry teammate dave did that for me
[ __ ] [ __ ] nobody grabbed me but it
didn't give him the tail
all right okay blue or losing orange or
losing that's good
ow okay he doesn't have a tail he's
coming to steal mine
no not likely no stay away likely
oh he took it but i took it i didn't
take it back okay
10 seconds green oh we're losing [ __ ]
[ __ ] i lost mine bro i lost
dude dude i got it i still have nothing
okay we're not losing we're not losing
qualify no
wait what we somebody lost their tail
right at the end ah
are you serious are you actually serious
you sound like forcing
i'm swedish in every syllable
[Laughter]
ah i tried to leave but it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] up
[ __ ] up last second snatch don't like
that
i don't like that we have to
i hate the mode that i won was the one
where it's all of you one person has the
tail at the very end
and whoever has it at the end of the
timer wins
and it's such [ __ ] it should be time
based
it's such [ __ ] did
and everybody like you're trying to grab
your dude and it's it's it's just
lagging dude it's just it's slash dude
stupid
all right six consoles
all right his name his name is also
felix i know cringe
oh squiggly camo
hell yeah no one will even see you yeah
you are the ugliest character i have
ever seen
bro my mom made this outfit for me
yeah yeah is she dumb
stupid or dumb
yeah what the [ __ ] that
yes
okay dude okay dude
i saw that uh people have been
complaining online over what's more
difficult youtube videos are streaming
but
we do both so uh cringe
imagine complaining on the internet
about [ __ ] anything
yeah never done that right just sign a
petition already and make it feel like
you're doing something
oh this one's easy i will maybe i will
maybe i [ __ ] went dude
wait i never done this easy
just hit start streaming go blah blah
blah blah blah
stream oh all right well he said it guys
that's not my opinion
uh i would actually say that it's really
tough to stream and it takes a lot of
mental capacity
and it's actually way harder than you
think not everyone can do it
it's literally not something anyone
could do god everybody's pushing me
so that's jack's opinion and i just want
to say
i do not align with that opinion that
does not align with my views
bro most people online don't even align
with their own opinions
that's true it's true ah the ball is
fake
what i squeezed through the ball what
the [ __ ] i don't know i could do that
yeah sometimes you can do that it's a
tactic
uh only if you're a streamer and work
really hard you could do it [ __ ] god
damn it
[ __ ] do i have to let people know that
i'm joking now as well
yet yeah before people actually think
that that was
all right it's already been taken out of
context dude
take certo are writing an article
already all right
all right come on i'm right behind you
dude come on dude
hell yeah that's teamwork that's because
we're youtubers and we work much harder
than streamers
it just comes naturally
that's a streamer movie
who's even complaining about this why is
it actually youtubers and streamers
complaining about it or is it just
people
no i i think it became a thing about
react videos and then it kind of
some people made it about what's harder
youtube or streaming but i
that's just like people deteriorating
from the the conversation
that's what i can make easy streams and
easy videos and you can make
streams in here yeah yeah exactly yeah
and at the end of the day just do what
you want to do
and yeah and thank you for the bits and
just like keep donating to the stream
yeah thank you thank you for the super
chats thanks for becoming a
tier 3 sub and i will post pictures of
myself
one toe at a time
you're ready to record again huh it
wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up
so yeah you wanna you wanna go make a
video bro
oh i fell right at the start i'm
literally last
oh no hot hot dog man [ __ ] yeah that's
some challenge
chad the country chad the country
i did not think you were gonna finish
the word country there
why are people going now they are so
annoying
god god god
stop [ __ ] no one likes you dude you're
trash dude
you're trash kid
but i am a man all right guys
work together here work together here
work together stop jumping on the
[ __ ] platform
god [ __ ] yeah rising tide raises
jump there there's not looking good for
me dude
oh get off it get off of you fat pigeon
don't [ __ ] call me a fake [ __ ]
pigeon
oh god i fell i'm sorry i tripped i'm up
again don't ruin this mother me this is
my one chance
yes on your feet soldier oh no [ __ ] yeah
i'm in
i'm not going to fail win win oh
god why everyone jumps on that and they
ruin both platforms
yeah both are [ __ ] stop jumping you
[ __ ] idiots stop
just stop jumping i jumped i jumped and
i failed [ __ ] i
deserve to fail oh i am just gonna
i'm a [ __ ] simp for these guys in
this platform
own your feet soldier please please
[ __ ] this is not going well everyone is
so greedy
yeah i'm right behind you this is the
worst place to be in because
everybody wants it everybody's thirsty
on your feet yeah okay we're working
together now
teamwork guys we can all make it
together just don't be greedy
they're just going to jump on that and
i'll fall off okay [ __ ] that
don't laugh at me don't laugh at me
don't laugh at me
oh what a hypocrite what do you mean
oh no oh and the last one through
he grabbed me let go of me you dirty
[ __ ]
i'm out i'm out did you qualify
yeah no all right
did you leave the match no i'm in it uh
i'll wait i'll wait i want to see you do
well
nah let's leave [ __ ] no no i'm already
gone
all right thank you there's like 29
people left i don't care about that
okay thank you it's probably gonna be
egg scramble next and i'm gonna want to
throw something
that's chad [ __ ] right there guys
you know stoicism taught me to always
control my anger
yeah i'm still still working on that one
i was playing this yesterday on stream
and everyone was like stoicism everybody
you need it for this [ __ ] game don't
[ __ ] call me
oh the chat call you out yeah damn
that's cold bruh
all right win win top of the mountain
top of the mountain to your left all we
all will see is each other bro
yeah lifting each other up holding hands
rising high
rising high rising above okay hit parade
easy
i just want a whole server full of these
ones the obstacle courses
yeah no games that's scary that's not
just like
luck of the irish yeah i don't even have
that
all i have is sheer raw talent oh i like
but isn't like a talent in a way no you
know that quote
it's strange the more i exercise or in
practice the luckier i become
oh it's so weird the more i try
the better chances of my success are
i'm in first bro no you're not no you're
really first early first i see you bro i
look at you and you're glowing bro
uh do people know how physics works
all right mid bro mid bro trying this is
a
mess oh god they all want to make it so
bad it's
oh i'm right next to you bro what's up
what's up dude
oh and i spinned it thank you i thought
i turned around and look at you and give
you a little wink
that was sexing me all right first place
yeah i always think
man there's so many people here i'm not
going to make it and then you're like
15th
there's so many people allowed through
yeah yeah in the first one but
it's also we're also really good gamers
that's true yeah that true daddy dude
everybody in chat and in the comments
tell us how amazing we are
um yeah i want at least one nice
compliment
i just like an echo chamber it's really
healthy for me
yeah i told my mods to ban everyone that
doesn't say something positive
yeah monsieur i just don't want to be
surrounded by yes men
burn him right now fuzzy vibes only
anyone all right i got a tail i got a
tail i don't got a tail but i
i got good vibes you know what i'm
saying
maybe i shouldn't steal from my
teammates this time got him yeah this is
really confusing one of our teammates
has like a pink top
he doesn't look super green i'm not sure
if i can uh trust him
okay another strategy is to stay with
stay with people who have tails already
okay because then they're not going to
steal yours and other people might steal
theirs instead
okay i say that but i immediately go
against 50 50 chance like i get it bro
yeah and then if they take your tail you
might be able to get the other person's
tail back
oh dude that's get it oh hey bro
hey what's up okay i'm next to someone
with that i'm just kidding
is it me oh [ __ ] oh that was scary
oh this is i got it hey you stole mine
oh sorry bro sorry about that one bro
[ __ ] why did i do that what a [ __ ] you
don't even have it
anymore i don't have it anymore i [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
god you're so annoying all right got it
i got it
oh my god people keep going by me and i
keep missing the tails
i'm the worst all right i gotta deserve
to be hunted
[ __ ] i don't i lost it bro
he stole it from our green and i got it
back immediately
okay how much time is that [ __ ] 30
seconds okay blue or losing stay away
from blues
go away red go right red yes come on how
is that even
i am gonna come on come on come on come
on 16 seconds
okay we're not losing that's good so
it's not my fault then
how did he make that out of line we're
good we're good we're good we're good
qualified
okay thanks to me thanks to me say
thanks
thank you fearless sorry i did nothing
who's in touch i did nothing that was
terrible i suck at this one
yeah me too
when i won it was that one at the very
end with the tail and there was only
three of us so it was super easy to stay
away from everybody
so i kind of feel like it doesn't count
come on we both qualified this is epic
yeah
yeah okay easy easy please all right you
stay pushing the ball i'm going straight
to the end to [ __ ] with people
what you push the ball i'm rushing ahead
and when other people's balls come down
i'm gonna block them
okay okay okay okay all right soldier
don't
okay
wait were you in pushing school
oh they had the same tactic all right
here comes orange ball
i'm ready to stop it all right a red
ball is struggling
i'm stopping it i'm sacrificing my my
life my life's on the line for this
uh yeah we got [ __ ] we got [ __ ] we got
[ __ ] over here okay orange are [ __ ]
as well
they haven't even left the starting
block down
i here even [ __ ] see there's so many
okay red ball why are you not going we
literally can't move
they glocked up they locked up the ball
it's the same with the orange ball so
it's whoever breaks free first i think
yeah but there's so many of the blue
okay blue or oh why aren't blue gone
through yet
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] orange is breaking free
[ __ ] the ball is landing on my head
they're smart they're smart i don't like
it
[ __ ] we're [ __ ] we're [ __ ] we're
[ __ ]
this is [ __ ] this mode sucks
smooth brain
okay orange is through focus on blue
instead oh god
get out of here
oh man it's all over it's all over man
i'll rather die than this happening oh
my god damn it
damn it the mode is terrible
you gotta grab the guys blocking yours
yeah people already picked up that strat
that we were doing
that's embarrassing oops yeah pretty
much people are here for wins jack not
for
some measly sleesley potato sliced
caesies
you know what i'm saying okay well let's
give it to them then let's give it to
them
all right you guys are hungry
you guys are hungry what are you in the
mood for what can we serve you
whatever you guys want dude why are you
still spectating
am i yeah oh sorry sorry
sorry about that bro
i'm gonna have words with you when the
stream is done
don't leave discord okay we we have to
talk
no the [ __ ] i'm not your girlfriend
[ __ ] off
[Laughter]
can't believe we'd say that on our
anniversary like this
unbelievable dude i'm i'm plugging out
your xbox after this
no no
no all right we gotta go now
thank you i said lyrics
what's the lyrics to star wars again
okay this one's easy if you fail at this
point saying
same i don't like it all right
yeah if we don't qualify on this one
then you might as well qualify in
another life
did you know that the person who runs
the fall guys twitter is oliver age24
you remember him who's that again he
that was a long time i heard that name
you give him a shout out in the same
shout out as me what the [ __ ]
yeah he used to work for bosses studios
that so yeah i think i remember that
i used to be a youtuber drawing like bad
pictures
oh [ __ ] that's him yes yes yes yes yes
that was a long time ago
now i remember yeah now he works for
fall guys
well there you go small world
well there you have it we should just
message him and ask for skins in the
game
uh can i get a potato skin pewdiepie
skin please
i'll give you a shout out you probably
pewdiepie wavy pattern hey bro remember
that shout out bro
women you're a cool you're
for you did you do it
it would it would be extremely painful
it would be
it would be extremely beneficial a
mutual
i don't know a mutual arrangement
haha say the funding haha he do voice
move down a bit oh my god no
okay what's your strategy for this one
why do we suck and you're better
no we qualify
yeah like chad is better than anyone
shut the [ __ ] up chat
shut the [ __ ] up
what do you get uh is it even worth
jumping on the first one because like
look at this yeah maybe not it's
probably better to wait i'm just going
to attack
actually i made it i'm in it because i'm
chad chad
chat chat chat chad you got to scream
chad all over that's it that's how you
do it you're saying chat
chat chat chat dude
damn you're way ahead now you're not
[ __ ] this up for me dude you're not
you're just not
i will not okay i passed the first two
[ __ ] you betas [ __ ]
virgins [ __ ] up
oh dude i'm on the last one hell yeah
dude
i've never been this good on this one i
realize the stratus is just
not be nice to other people
fine the greedy wins literally
all right i'm in dude i got third what
the [ __ ]
damn how'd you get third when it says
only two qualified
because there was one if i went and i
would have been third i'm not going in
yet oh
i'm waiting for my bro bro i see you bro
i'm on the way back here hello
hello i [ __ ] suck
i'll i'll inspect you
dude we got 69 likes on the stream sorry
chad i take it back you're
wonderful chat chat
chat chat chat is this you are you
no i'm okay
i'm right at the end qualifying bro oh i
see you bro
you're glowing bro not grabbing me [ __ ]
nice see i picked the track
yeah i picked the cactus skin so they
can't grab me yeah
that's smart your mom is smart i said
dumb before
no she's not she gave birth to me she's
an idiot
self-roast bro
potato i taste better roasted
i told marcha what potato is in swedish
and she thought it was the hilarious but
i don't think it's funny
what is it
that sounds made up no it's real
but tarties put out these mom
i'm thinking about patotties for dinner
what do you think
an irish it's protei party
yeah oh nice wait which one is this you
just jump right
yeah oh this is easy we're gonna you
know if you jump on each other
if you jump on each other's heads you
can get up on the side and dodge
everything
oh really oh is that what they're trying
to do
yeah i watch stream fails it's whatever
uh we're gonna make my god we gotta make
it so obnoxious
yeah right i hate it i hate the pushing
mechanism
yeah just leave that for the like tail
tank modes
you're good you're good you're good
you're good come on triceratops you got
this
you're like how do you fail on this tell
me how
why even put that in there
how do you fail at this it's gonna get
harder
last 30 seconds i know and if these
things get you they just stick to you
and you never get up again you're done
done oh yeah i'm done i'm done yeah i
got stuck
i got [ __ ] i got [ __ ] stuck
literally you said it you [ __ ] said
it and it happened this is so
[ __ ] dog [ __ ]
[ __ ] how do you lose at this one
oh clip it clip it
see you on reddit not in the mood
all right let's see you do it then dude
i'm a [ __ ]
legend at this game legend 27
how do i even know who i'm expecting
yeah why doesn't it prioritize friends
because it's a good game
where you get stuck in the floor dude
cringe how did you lose this
yeah i'll win it for i'll win it for us
bro win for me bro
ah that dude has skeletons on him
yeah that's probably why he qualified a
knight in uh i just want to say
that wasn't like uh i thought it would
be funny to do the thing that you said
and then i did it so
it's a little it's a joke it's a
different content
content you know what it is all right
you can win it i believe i just got to
make sure i inspect you
yeah i'm the cactus
i played this before yeah i got you i
played this before and my tactic was
like i'm just gonna be patient and then
i got
left behind completely
oh god where's the star to this okay
there it is
what are you doing yeah i'm just waiting
for people i'm not going
yeah but that's what i did and then they
left me dude
nice nice jump are you are you insane
[ __ ]
dude i'm cracked oh my god look at all
these blocks
what was that shut up okay
i'm trying here
don't you dare try and grab me you
[ __ ]
okay i'm literally just gonna wait for
them to figure it out i'm not doing
anything else
from here on yeah that's what i did be
careful
you should be on the last block just so
you can jump
yeah okay okay go go nice dude
nice that tricky little gap at the very
end
no it's not so tricky i never fell at it
i actually never failed
you just failed before you get to the
round shut them don't they don't know if
they just clicked on the stream
okay okay that's felix right there next
to me see yeah
yeah dude they don't know if you're
spectating or not you're good
just just say it's you bro okay bro i
mean okay here we go
is this the finals all right don't jump
showdown's back
jump shot down final first time final
because we just started that's why
first round first round let's go let's
get it
let's escalate and scat
okay so this was only added back in like
two hours ago
what do you mean they removed this from
the game
this mode why oh [ __ ]
how do you know so much about follow
them on twitter
cringe you didn't even have a twitter
i mean nice that's cringe plato came to
me in a dream and i was like uh can't
have twitter anymore
oh my god this [ __ ] sucks don't you i
know it
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] god the floor disappears
now this
[ __ ] sucks but why did they remove it
i don't know i think it was kind of
broken or something okay
i see how it is
oh well it's much better now no oh no
everyone's just gonna lose on the same
oh yeah you're not gonna win bro oh [ __ ]
you're not gonna win bro
you [ __ ] oh god yeah you have to pick
your own
i think i could pay attention
okay i don't want to see the winner i
don't care turn it off
turn it off no turn the tvs off no i
want to see who wins
cringe jack didn't win cringe
it says i have one win though no i just
have one crown that it's not me to win
[ __ ] yeah i got sex without that too
yeah that's cringe
can't even buy anything with one crown
can you
no that's full of suck that's a good
that's a good final yeah
but i the floor disappearing like that
it's just pure random look then
yeah it's just final round should always
be skill based
yeah you should tweet that to them
i should i have a twitter
i have a big following that i can abuse
send someone's way and bully them make
sure you make
them um make them cry so they understand
you're not [ __ ] around i should start
a hashtag too
so it'll trend and more people can see
it
[Music]
all right this is the easiest one i
never failed this
if you fail at this you better that's
exactly how it is
i only failed once at this and that was
earlier on when everyone was watching so
that's embarrassing
okay here we go here we go here we go
here we go now
i'm literally winning bro
i see you bro look at my eyes bro oh
[ __ ] the [ __ ] yellow thing got me
uh-oh winning bro winning team stop
pushing me
nerds dude i'm winning by a lot what
happened
what the [ __ ] use the tactic fall down
win game oh you idiot you [ __ ] me
you [ __ ] me god
damn it oh god i'm lagging
are you winning not anymore what
happened
no did you get hit by the balls
how did he get hit by the ball oh like i
don't even know it was such a
it almost happened again [ __ ] yeah i'm
not gonna make it i'm not gonna make it
there's way too many yeah leave leave
before
[ __ ] that's ever embarrassing that's so
much
because no one can sing
you had to say
i'm a pigeon now it doesn't matter ready
ready just ready no one knows
okay i'm i'm i'm not a i'm not a beta
stop to call me better that's not funny
that's not funny guys you shouldn't say
mean stuff from the in there you could
hurt people's feelings
have you thought of that yeah you
[ __ ] morons yeah
how dare you say anything [ __ ] mean
to me you should yeah [ __ ]
think about think about his feelings
dude they're calling you beta
cringe damn i got through so
oh oh did you yeah oh yeah oh did you
literally have video proof oh really
okay
this one's easy see those propellers go
right between where it's showing there
you never get hit what do you mean
when it's the three propellers go
between the two right ones right where
they connect
what do you mean okay just [ __ ] lose
then
just want to know what you mean where
the blades are overlapping the
propellers
yeah but what do you mean okay i'm done
talking to you i'm just gonna win
instead
what are you saying oh if you're so good
why am i winning bro
literally right beside me literally
winning that fight
oh my god it's tossing around like a
[ __ ] pedal i'm fine
so how do i get right next to the edge
you don't it's cringe
all right only people who think they're
awesome at the game grab the edge
see right through right through the
propellers right here right between
where they connect
and you never get hit okay so oh i got
it i got it
what the [ __ ] you're lying son of a
[ __ ] never never [ __ ]
you [ __ ] light him why am i swearing
so much sorry
you lied okay i did get hit i did get
here did you go between the two on the
right or the one on the left
uh right but i still made it bro so it's
okay i'm not mad or anything
i'm just kind of just don't do that
again
oh god god they're so cringe like if
other people would stop touching me i
would like this game so much more
yeah it's so [ __ ] annoying if you
play this game and you wait at the
finish line to stop other people
you have problems
i've done it a couple times but i do
know i have a problem
are you thrilled it's always done i'm
through
elon musk if you're watching
tweet me orange
[ __ ] imagine liking elon in august of
hey you take that back forever forever
don't care [ __ ] you forever stan
forever got tesla stock and they test
even if he tweets stupid [ __ ] all the
time forever sim
no no they're not always stupid take
that back
take that back sometimes he posts
something about tesla
okay what's next what's next what's up
you say things about me
uh mike lechowski face or whatever okay
krachowski you say sting by elon
you're done apologize
ever all right he's never gonna play
fall guys with you dude stop trying elon
please tweet me i want to play forget
with you
please i can't wait until he actually
tweets something about fall guys
you know what's going to happen uh-huh
yeah when
tomorrow all right ellen you wanna might
wanna schedule your next tweet
you might wanna warm up those thumbs
there elon
all right it's gonna get hot think about
the retweets
we're going to make an alien i do not
want to be near other people on this
level
yeah it's fun and i immediately go where
everybody is
dude this music slaps you think so i
think it's super annoying
okay you you [ __ ] rude man i don't
tell you man
oh god he's touching me he's [ __ ]
touching me and i
i've gotten so close to falling off
multiple times yeah me too that was
really close
wait so that many more has to get
eliminated it just keeps going
yep oh god
kill me then
yeah i wish this one was timed as well
yeah
okay eight more people have to go out
[ __ ] hell
boom boom this music sounds like a
spiral or crash bandicoot level
okay only six more
yeah it hasn't changed
four more easy easy
easy oh god
oh god i hate this uh two more one more
nice
nice yeah
i did it on a stream for like a couple
of hours and i never went back to it for
some reason
this is too much story in the beginning
it's kind of hard to
yeah i think you'd like it though
i think i would like to stream you think
so
yeah so much meme potential i know that
the meme
is there but uh slime time this is my
mode
i never done this what do i do okay so
slime
is rising i'm winning i don't know i
don't need advice from someone when i'm
winning okay
i'm winning okay okay i'm [ __ ]
winning what do you do just don't
just don't get it what are you doing get
knocked in what are you doing right next
right next to you bro what are you doing
right next to you bro
oh my god oh my god oh my god
somebody grabbed me don't grab jack man
this is my mode dude
i got this
oh god they're so annoying and i hate
them
oh no oh no is this over am i gonna have
to like face
the [ __ ] firing squad
no no i'm out why what happened are you
[ __ ] serious
i i miss time to
ah i've never lost that [ __ ] mode
no [ __ ] hurry i'm trying to find you
how do i do these barrels like what's
the strat
i don't even know where you are
i didn't why not where are you
i'm the pigeon are you [ __ ] off oh
you're a pigeon now not a
are you being grabbed yes
oh god oh oh god
all right it's okay you'll spend your
time
this isn't even really about qualifying
because a lot of people will end up just
falling off
oh lord all right the rest is easy you
just gotta make sure you take your time
i
don't let these dudes grab you but he's
grabbing me they're so
[ __ ] annoying oh my god
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that guy
[Music]
don't even care stoicism bro
dude i just face my mortality every day
anyway
whatever pain life throws at me is i can
endure it
i saw that coming too you're not you're
not slick whoever tonight you ain't
slick
you ain't [ __ ] slick you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] the same as the rest of us you're
not special
[ __ ] what [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm leaving i'm leaving i already left
i didn't leave yet because i was so
angry
bad game uninstalled
oh i got a
no bro
if i get if i make it to level 10 i get
the
1000k things
huh epic
i know that means but cool all right
redemption arc coming right up
i got it i got it now got it now
got it now this is the one bro
this is the one bro okay you got it i
got it you got it
dude i you got it i'm chill i'm chill
yeah i got it yeah
you got it i got it yeah yeah
[ __ ] oh no you don't got it bro
i don't i lost it bro i'm gonna be
honest with you bro
all right okay i got a strong feeling
about uh
okay all right so this is the strat here
it's right here is to wait for all these
[ __ ]
i ain't waiting i'm greedy yeah i got
off a bad start and now i'm gonna lose
and i'm angry no no no no no you're good
you're good you got this
strong strong strong boy
strong let's let those [ __ ] go on
that one
there you go oh no i'm not going on that
oh
actually never mind i think i will i
think i'll summer over here for a week
there we go there we go there we go can
i make it right
oh yes they fell nice there's almost no
one with me now so
yeah i see you you're far ahead dude
it's kind of in the clear
you're like you're like the wind right
now bro dude eight percent speed of
light
i shouldn't have done that bro now i
have to simp for these
dudes oh my god you idiots
stop jumping on it [ __ ] yeah i like the
dudes who are in the front
because they kind of know they're going
through so it's all just like yeah after
you bro
yeah it's so much nicer in the back
it's like a black friday so i was like
no i'm running
i i'm not gonna make it bro you're gonna
make it there's loads of time
i see you i see you i wave that's not a
wave
there it is
no i'm so close
i'm sweating i'm sweating bro
you got it you got it you're better
you're better
you're good he's one shot okay
[ __ ] i can't do it i need the
inspiration song
okay this dude is trying to push me over
into the finish line
you're better you got it
i hate how i have to help these guys
they're so stupid they're just
they're just going to steal all your
[ __ ] now
okay go go go go go yes yes yes yes yes
yes
no no no
you got it you got it you got it you're
serious come on
hitting
i was bumping your chest bro
i was bumping it i don't know bro sounds
kind of weird what you did
bro no not like that
not like that i mean it's fine oh just i
wasn't ready for it
not like that no no okay
okay big game big games big games what
is it all right
give me hoops i like the hoops i want
the hoops
or nothing i guess what the [ __ ]
oh no we made it but at what cost
all right memory easy three tiles you
gotta remember
three tiles every time apparently
what the [ __ ]
okay i'm in the back that's good oh i'm
in the back too so i got the
four on the left okay
watermelon banana
okay i'm waving at you bro
which one do you weigh with so there's
emotes on that
i'm too focused remembering watermelon
banana right now so don't talk to me
no no
i pressed e because you said emo
say the number keys no you said
i did not you said you said
i can't with you right now
i did not say e check
why i totally always focus on bananas as
well
i told you i was well it was watermelon
on bananas unbelievable
you said the number keys
i heard ease of course you did
i did it's not the fault of
mine
jack superior stay jack
jack's the best jack i love him
wish i could kiss his chest
ew ah this is the pure luck one
yeah i want to qualify so bad
we're gonna do it all right all right
let's go i was pressing the e button
again
[ __ ] so it's not i didn't even know e
made you dive
yeah right i thought it was just right
click
i thought it was uh all right here we go
epic door this is one bro
uh he worked
straight all the way through the door
straight all the way hell yeah bro
get it again sniff it out sniff it out
what is it [ __ ]
i only ain't that one cringe
oh my god i'm stuck back here with the
[ __ ] herd of cattle yeah if you get
the cattle
you ain't you're in the squad you're all
sheep
oh is this one
oh hell yeah if you dive out through it
people kind of push you out
oh god there's okay i could win i could
win i couldn't
left left left don't forget to jump it
oh no
you don't need to jump at the end of
this one don't forget to jump i'm gonna
i'm gonna jump bro
top ten top ten top ten top ten top i
was fifteen
top fifteen bro bro
you're just dude clap i cut for you bro
i clap for you bro cause you're amazing
oh
dude together we can accomplish anything
i feel like we are
stronger if if individual bad
team good dude apes together strong
[Music]
are you calling me april
no no no apes one time bro
yeah i remember yeah
is that where
we all ate we all know it who cares
it's a champion there's a chain you sh
chant
it's a chain it's a shame you can't oh
actually i'll ask you in a second uh
it's a shame you can't play this lion
because that would be really cool yeah
to shame this game is not good i mean
sorry shame this game it's so good
please give me skin they're never gonna
give me skin that's too controversial
let's get rid of it
it'll be a ninja skin before mine
oh pewdiepie uh some people don't like
him so no he can't have skin
come on show your shad fallout fallout
boys whatever whatever this game is
called
i'm a big fan all right sugar we're
going down
swinging bro
uh press e for emotes and then you go
faster
to be chad
that's actually good oh hey bruh
especially
for chat for chat go to other streamers
and tell them hey
emotes are on e on a level where he
makes sense
that's a good troll f4 [ __ ]
is so all that for some dead meme i
cringe every time i see it
yeah there's too many buttons to press
that gives people time to think about it
oh god i might is this it for me oh [ __ ]
no oh oh holy [ __ ] macaroni smelly
[ __ ]
dude you're italian your your italian's
getting better thank you bro
that was insane [ __ ] clip there three
more three more
jesus christ two more two more we're
good
oh no oh no yeah oh this is it
okay we're in bro no no one more one
more one more
i climb for you because you're amazing i
crave for you because you amazing
you the snack
are we bro are we cringe yeah definitely
this whole thing is green we're making
crazy compilation bro
do you ever go in being like man no it's
gonna be different today
it could be mature i'm not gonna be
cringe today i gotta be cool
you ever wake up no i'm not gonna be
cringe today yeah not not today
no i've decided against it
and then hit record
today i'm not gonna make the top reddit
cringe
compilation page yeah front page not
today bro
not today i'm going to be irrelevant
today
i've decided
yeah that's the that's the tactic you
need to be self-aware cringe
yeah yeah yeah if you're self-aware dude
it's so epic
you can get away with anything all right
um
say middle front yeah but why did i die
last time
because if the thing on the bottom hits
you it kind of like you kind of get
stuck
in it and then you can't jump yeah but
how do i avoid it
you jump first for [ __ ] sake
it's not that hard how did your brain
get so large explain
at large it's wrinkle more wrinkled more
smart ah
[ __ ] i keep ironing my brain bro
i wake up blow dry my hair iron my brain
smooth out those wrinkles bro smooth
brain
i used to talk about i use a steamer
actually
okay okay okay here he comes here comes
[ __ ] you
i'm not gonna epic all right cool on top
that was great all right hey do it again
oh [ __ ] dude
dude you're popping off right now i am
going left and right and up and down and
dude i am falling and i can get up
oh my god everybody else hitting you
though is so annoying
okay and last 30 seconds is a [ __ ]
gauntlet
what does gauntlet mean in english
it's like it just keeps coming at you
[ __ ] get on the gauntlet get up
soldier
on your feet like this this is the
gauntlet look at it go
so hard so problem
all right cool cool cool cool don't
patronize me because i could fail this
easily
please let me do it i'm gonna hype
myself up more than anything
oh god okay oh that was close oh my god
dude there's not that many of us left
yeah we got a lot of people jesus christ
all right this is it
all right we've been together all this
time but now we've been nine
top stop then now i hate you then
jack's a guy more like jackson uh dude
this is the roast
the roast part three part three but you
wait did we do it
iron your brain dumbass oh no we're
together on this one nevermind
i love you bro
i love you bro i always said it bro
let's go
teamwork bro never deny it all right all
right uh
shoot i go okay
okay okay i'm terrible at it but at
least i'm here
yeah yeah yeah easy first goal done
easy pc squeeze my okay kick off kick
kick off kicker
okay i got this ball oh got the kick out
of here
suck my tits off no
[ __ ] [ __ ] don't hit it dude don't hit it
dude i got it i got it i got it no
i'm not hitting it i'm not hitting it
i'm ready for the kickoff
uh no no no no i fell i fell in the hole
you posted cringe bro no oh i'm the
[ __ ] cringiest
grab him not the ball [ __ ]
okay uh bro
other way [ __ ] sake
this is going terribly yeah
oh my god both balls are here get up
this is bad this is bad no it's good so
bad
oh that's great that's a great bounce on
that one
no [ __ ] bangles around here bro
bangles i'm just going to grab their
goalkeeper
nice nice that's set up that's set up
centered
centered tactic oh
oh no don't send those balls back here
i'm not ready
god sometimes i swear i don't understand
the physics of this
perfect game bro send it off to esports
it's ready
[ __ ] [ __ ] it boys
[ __ ] dude you're so jersey with this
thank you josie was [ __ ] right now
okay we might get one here damn it
yeah right oh watch out for that guy
not today bro oh you got plane
[ __ ]
okay it's it's just going to go into
overnight [ __ ]
oh yeah this is good if it's in overtime
first goal wins
oh this is good is that good
well the ball is on their side so it
seems like it might be good
oh god i hate this
so anxious we [ __ ] up they got it they
got it they got it
no no that's really bad batman
oh god yes dude that was amazing
that was amazing
oh no come on come on gamers
come on there you go there you go there
you go yes yes that one that one that
one that one's going in [ __ ]
come on oh come on it's so close so
close so close so
class i'm back here i'm waving at you
bro motivation suck loss bro
all right i'm grabbing your [ __ ] ass
i'm grabbing your [ __ ] ass come here
i'm grabbing oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
they're coming
and grabbing i got him i got him he's
done nice
nice he's done and nice he's done
you're done get it blue get it blue nice
get it out it worked holy [ __ ] yes yes
yeah hell yeah [ __ ]
orange they're yellow they're yellow
whatever they're not blue that's what's
important
oh big wrinkle plain that's what
wrinkles does okay we can work together
to get this last one
wait what is it this is the one whoever
has the tail at the very end wins
okay which is complete [ __ ] because
i feel like it should be based on
whoever has it the longest
tweeted so if i just say it in a stream
to millions of people
and said okay who has it orange guy over
here has it
get him get him pin him off nice now i
can keep people away from you
a win for one is a win for all a win for
one win for all
okay just go just go just go
i got him i got him i got him [ __ ] those
guys god two minutes is way too [ __ ]
long
no stop him nice got it i got it i gotta
win for one this win i got him
okay dude i am a legend at this wait
till you see
i got him
all right they're not him near you bro
good good good good
oh my god my camera [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
kidding me
how did he just teleport that to his
hands
got it bro oh god i almost took it from
you
good good good good good good
god i'm nervous dude this could be it's
all good bro it's all good bruh
nice oh [ __ ] i got hit oh bro i'm not
there get off it get off it
no no no no no no no no no it's pro
strats
post not gonna work they're if they the
lag will just let them take it from you
oh [ __ ] the lag bro
told you bro
it showed me grabbing him it made the
sound where is it where is he he turned
the firing far in fahrenheit
he's up on him oh i can't get there
[ __ ] come on come on i don't even know
you can go there
smoke him out smoke him out send him my
way oh you got him
[ __ ] 20 seconds what is he doing
come on i want it oh you're so close
are you serious are you serious i'm
spamming the button
you're not supposed to spam it bro [ __ ]
it's all over where'd he go [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you all right doesn't even matter
sucks suck [ __ ]
that was fun though yeah ggs everybody
that was good the leg
i got [ __ ] by the leg every time
goddamn boy
i'm so close to get my thousand case
so close you can get it i believe in you
i believe it's you are you are you like
down for more or
always really bro
yeah bro hell let's go bro
we can do a few more rounds gamers stay
winning gamers win win
win we were close we got a taste there
that was a little nibble
that was a little desert what is it
called eskar no
uh a pair of teeth apparently
oh david's playing should we get there
and a moose boosh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
backing up bro backing up bro uh invite
players uh
david they saw the booster
there he is got adam discord um
i looked for added added him oh yeah
this
hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello
we're live don't say bad word okay cool
not that you normally do
just saying okay great all right he's
totally calling you out right now
dave in background real bad guy if you
can last for 10 seconds
uh we're live
[Music]
[Laughter]
hello if you if you could just mute dave
such a such a loaded sentence we're live
don't say anything bad
instead of just saying we're lying
are you saying dave says bad words all
the time yeah i do have a problem
cringe we all have problems
okay i think this is easy see dave see
where those two propellers are about to
meet there but
but like where right where the blade
tips are about to tip each other
but like where that works he keeps
asking me that and he [ __ ] it up and
i'm sick of him
should we just wait and show him no
because then we lose because he sucks
but like where i qualified last time
that's nice but i qualified first
how many have you got so far ten nine
ten nice oh i meant nine plus ten
right that's what i thought i thought
you meant until since you like joined
the call
oh right
the [ __ ] i wasn't even touching it
okay i guess i'm climbing in this one
can't believe ah
the [ __ ] propeller come on man
all right all right you guys through
yeah nice oh [ __ ] you're right you don't
even
have to jump on that propeller bit nope
hey dude oh
dude [ __ ] big balls on you me
yeah you just went straight forward i
was like okay time this i forgot that
that was there
bro what i keep saying bro i'm so
[ __ ] annoying
bro i don't think you're annoying open
your eyes bro
all right we're qualified you guys
saying it makes me less annoying
yeah okay dave top 10 dave what
character are you top 10 i'm done
so man okay i'm trying to find you
top 10.
now i could totally get this i could
totally get this which character you at
bro oh there you go you're through now
right nearly nearly walking towards the
finish line yeah yeah yeah
don't let that guy grab you [ __ ] that
guy no no
oh he almost [ __ ] that up for you no
i would have been so mad for you if he
did that yeah
this is easy how much like you have
control over this one
like how much it feels like when you
lose it you feel like it's your fault
you know you
you know that's sorry i like these
obstacle course ones it should just be
all these
no [ __ ] egg scramble no bald [ __ ]
sick of it no
who is dave we found him on street in
okay easy kind of looks like a homeless
guy right now his parents were leaving
the cinema
unfortunately dave and there was a
burglar at the back alley
dude your improv skills are crazy
yeah you're picking up skills even
better shut the [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i'm i'm winning dude
[Music]
you know what all right i actually think
this is the most skilled based one
out of all of them i clap for you bro
we clap for each other yeah good job
good yule bro can you turn on kurosawa
mode
too much color it's just lightning and
wind in the background all the time
okay easy roll out dude
now we have three of us we filled the
server even more higher chances
that's true dude
simple math
uh i don't okay dave you're the dinosaur
you're right now i see you that's right
yeah
i see you bro dinosaur right i'm the
pigeon
oh you're the pigeon i've always been
man i always has been i'm the cactus
oh [ __ ] this bad this bad
grabbing me man son burnt pickle
uh you just got to find a group that's
wholesome and doesn't hurt each other
find a group [ __ ] that was close good
advice for life really
yeah this is tough ones over here
usually the edge is easier
some of these ones are so much harder if
there's a bunch of people
okay six people are out so we're almost
halfway
i like when you find the one that goes
on forever yeah right
you can just you can just kind of chill
out for a bit yeah it
finally happened on this side
[ __ ] no one's going out
is there a time nope
just until we hit 13 eliminations damn
yeah oh my god i went on the [ __ ]
smallest one i've ever seen
what is this there's a there's a dude
who has like a red top and a like
bare bottom and he keeps trying to pull
people off
stay away from him he's he's he's mean
toxic
toxic okay this is a good one that's a
good one
okay we're 9-13
brody thank you so much brody thank you
oh why did i try so hard on that one
what the [ __ ]
oh can people can people really start
going out please
come on okay purple's good
okay ten
oh god maybe we should stop being toxic
dame no i'll [ __ ] it up first thing to
the dark side
okay two more come on
oh someone's gone are they oh i thought
they were
this is going on forever
just one more one more yes yeah well
done boys
well done job gamers gamers
epic
thank you so much do you think it's
gonna be football or ex
didn't react good enough for brody brody
you're a real bro
thank you so much okay you're the
[ __ ] man
you're the [ __ ] man all right people
wish they were you brody
damn i wish i was brody it is a cooler
name than dave at least
yeah yeah too real
the most common name okay i'll stay in
gold smith
uh we want the most amazing of this just
blocking their goalkeeper maybe that's a
strat
yeah all right i'll be goalie
somebody grab goalie and somebody's
striker there's too many goalies though
damn what a bounce there's only one now
so they're called
oh grab their goalie okay i'm going
towards that
[ __ ] do some goalie grabbing ah
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you got this boys you got this boys make
me proud boys
on your feet on your fate boys
oh oh open goal open goal go up and go
they're about to do battle in an open
field okay now we grab goalie now we'll
grab a goalie yes
go baby okay get ready for kickoff
oh we have two people there good oh yes
yes yes
two goals two goals okay get ready for
kickoff again
yes oh he he was ready
yes it's a good one oh hi guys we're
killing it the realest the illest
killing the game kill oh oh watch out
guys watch out guys
right over me it's all right we scored
it we scored as well we scored as well
as long as there's no gold egg or some
[ __ ] we should be okay wait there one
didn't count
they got a gold but it didn't count oh
no it's counted
wow
really bro really
[ __ ] i shot it backwards i'm so sorry
about that bros
that's good that's good that's fine we
got we got defenders
we got defenders yes we scored again we
started again we got midfielders this is
crazy i've never been so high scoring on
this on this one
really bro brody wrote again hype i'm
biggest fan brody
yeah what are you guys doing thank you
thank you okay
i'm too focused on the game brody but
thank you so much oh another goal
dude we're killing it all right this one
oh god they got the gold
no that's just a weird ball that's a
football golden egg
no you're a big egg it's a golden eager
i want to see that remain 7-1 cringe
dude
oh can we get this one get the weird one
oh
almost still totally counts bro's mom is
gonna be pissed
no brother's mom safe investment
thank you your son is wonderful thank
you
thank you bro he's going to college for
sure he's going to college
and chad isn't
yeah get [ __ ]
you bunch of degreeless swine
do you guys both have degrees i do
nice degree gang totally finished mine
yeah
hot hot dog degree
[Music]
okay remember you have to actually press
shift to grab the crown at the end not
just jump into it
remember lads whoever loses
gets shot delete chain
are we all going the same [ __ ] route
all right could be anyone's game it
could be anyone's game
could be anyone what the [ __ ] is
happening with this this is oh
this is it oh i got shot i'm feeling it
i'm way out in front
oh dude jack
[ __ ]
oh you still got it jack oh oh
no no my god oh my god oh my god
[Music]
the guy who was trying to pose us off
the other level one
goddamn oh second twice in a row
oh man
that was a great game gamers gamers
gamers gamers
saw class no i think i can do one
one last one one last one okay okay
do it for brody this is for brody
that was so damn close well at least we
were top five
top three yeah if i didn't get hit by
the ball i would have had it
yeah well i was in front of you
you weren't yes i was
yes you i was a trailblazer on that one
it was lag chad said it
chad said as well
in fact like this game has been lagging
for like three weeks for me
if you're new in the live stream we have
uh uh how many wins do we have so far
how many how many have i counted well no
13 not 12. i think there was a number
uh chubs where the [ __ ] you been mate
welcome back how many wins 20
at least how many counts
every every round you qualify is a win
[ __ ] oh this is terrible
you get yeah sometimes
you jump right but then there's just so
many people you're like oh god
sometimes it helps you though and it
like pushes you to the end
so how do you skip the box
oh you do like that okay got it you just
gotta be good oh god i got stuck on the
fan i hate that dave you're so far ahead
yeah oh damn you guys are gonna qualify
not me this is cringe
i'm going to try you will i'm posting
cringe right now oh dave
dave it's not going to work man it
worked
whoa dude he's off the hizzle
the hazel the sizzles
oh my god if you guys push me off i i
will post cringe
don't do it bro it's not worth it bro
second place nice
yeah let go of me you peppermint i'm
definitely qualifying
definitely uh no you're not i'm
[ __ ] okay 14. take it take it i got it
i got a rough start i got a rough start
take it take it out
really the illidan fella the illa is the
realest kid let's go real estate pillars
hey oh
boy boy
looks like we got some gamers coming in
oh
you're holding everybody back ain't
happening [ __ ]
it's not a cringe compilation live
stream please
stop saying cringe stop it's not funny
mario party but with 60 players
kind of yeah it feels like we've been
playing more party again it's fun
it's a good game it's good [ __ ]
i want a mode in this where you get
power-ups is this the way you can like
steal
no no this one is too stressful i can't
i can't
do it i can't this would be a fun game
if you got to do teams that were like
just four
people like 20 teams of four people or
something
yeah because even now like we work
together as a team on most of them but
at the end
it's still technically only one of us
wins no we win together that's
that why would you say that that [ __ ]
only one of us ends up on podium bro
what the [ __ ] did we're a team what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] did we played again
what if what the [ __ ] dude i think that
dude
the last one is in this game no no
kill him no no
hey bro hi you something in the middle
there
you were in a weird spot there
oh my god he might be
is he grabbing people i'm grabbing
people now too
someone's got to die bro oh no we've
lost him
did you get one no but it was close i
feel bad
yeah you sounded like you felt bad i
feel terrible
i feel so bad hey don't [ __ ] touch me
oh sorry i was you forgot branch
big red arrow above your head oh sorry
forgot oh sorry i forgot how game work
sorry oh felix what are you doing
uh cringe bro somebody what are you
doing
i'm winning oh this one's fast oh i
don't like that
let's stay on blue it's nice
uh so really you just gotta change
platforms instead
oh my god stop crapping me i won't say
it
i won't say it that's gotta be say what
your mom is
um i'm trying not to be toxic we qualify
because teamwork
all right this is it this is the dinner
we got it
this is the round this is the round bye
bye stinkies
oh [ __ ] off cringe
uh how do i mutes i don't know all right
adeline rodriguez it's been fun for
seven years thank you for the content
thank you ellie thank you so much
very generous of you thank you for
supporting egg scramble
favorite let's pick a team to just screw
over
okay all right who do we hate
uh whatever what if we're red
this is accurate this is some point all
right blue
yeah we don't forget the eggs in the
beginning though
uh how the [ __ ] do i keep forgetting
there's a tactic where if you go into
the opposing team you can jump and just
throw the eggs right into the middle
and then someone else can grab them from
the middle
okay we hate blue blue stink sorry
whoops
huh there's still eggs in the middle why
is everyone so slow at this time
let go of it my guy we're on the same
team
okay cool we're all we were all level
there for a second give me that gold
it's scary
i got the gold all right it's my goal
time to abuse blues oh sorry
we have no one on defense guys
please oh my god the physics just breaks
in the defense please okay i'll head
back for defense
dude defense there's no one
stop okay i'm coming
oh gold egg
that's our egg that's our egg yes yes
throw it
oh my god we're losing guys but by the
way we're losing
by the way no we're not orange is losing
yeah that changed
and that can change fast blue is blue
it's [ __ ] us over it is so annoying
nah i got him i got him i'm here i'm
here bro
good
okay i grab gold egg and i hide in base
nine eight oh we got this nice
good job boys well playing well playing
well played i grabbed the wrong egg i
grabbed the wrong egg
all right yeah good defense
but good team spirit good
good vibe that whole time through that i
felt really good yeah
that whole point where we were racist
against one color
worked out great
is it
what was that you guys pushed i'm going
straight to the end to [ __ ] them over
yeah
you said that last time bro and it
didn't [ __ ] work
well it's not my fault you guys can't
push fast enough
all right we need pushers and we need
steers
okay i'm pushing we need to steer from
to the side here
okay we're we're winning we're good
we're good no
anymore no anymore there we go
oh god we're losing all right it's all
down to you
okay i'm stopping blue i'm stopping blue
and orange at the same time okay we got
it we got it
we got it we got it that's clear stop
the other one
has an unfair advantage on this because
the red here will just stop for a second
when it hits the pole
and then it takes a while to go in so if
the blue and the red get exactly the
same with blue goes in first
uh all i know is we qualified so i'm not
listening yeah
i honestly didn't listen either wait
what are you saying
it doesn't matter say it we're team
okay so you see the pole there watch the
blue wall it'll hit the pole and go in
oh it just okay it's slightly dead but
yeah if it's right in the side it takes
a little longer
no unfair game unplayable it almost
feels like the
remote is better we're top 10 gamers
again
back to back it's happening live
z back to back this is the one
it's like we're gamers or something
okay it's going to be the tail grab for
sure this is not the final is it
it is oh yep okay
this one changed no if your disappears
yeah we know we know we know if we all
spread out then our chances are way
higher right
hey i'm just [ __ ] saying it like it
is man
all right i'm i'm not saying next okay
you stay there dave i'll go over here
okay wait
oh god all right cool
all right zone defense we got this
all right dude oh my god he grabbed me
these guys suck all right we're
splitting two now dave is in the
superior one
or is it jack it's jack i've got three
over here yeah yeah
but i've also got four people so it's
annoying
yeah we're done we're done yeah that
kind of sucks that you're just
out
[Music]
all right come on come on come oh no
come on jack you got this
oh god easy easy
oh my god
why stay so far away oh god you're
making me nervous
come on jack come on come on jack
jack jack jack jack
think about how chad it will be to win
oh it's none of them are falling now
think about the testosterone
supplements anymore bro you're getting
lifetime supply
oh that's a that's a tough one dude
how did the other dude get through it oh
bro that's
that's a yx man [ __ ] dude i can't all
right
well that's that's rough that's that's
rough but so is life good game all i'm
thinking is like what would marcus
aurelius do you know
it's a [ __ ] this [ __ ] this game
that's how he controlled his own yeah
marcus aurelius [ __ ] them kids
[ __ ] gigs that [ __ ]
i jumped i swear i jumped
alright boys good game nice
gg classic all right
catch you on the flipsies
i had to end it on the cringe all right
bye
all right that was so fun what a great
impromptu
stream that was i didn't really read
chat but i'll uh have a moment
of solitude with your boys if you feel
like hanging around
uh dave off the map yeah i should have
done that
i was thinking about that
i think all of them disappeared except
that red one so i got nothing to read
well if you donate and i didn't see it
i'm sorry we're
just focusing on the game having fun and
i hope it was entertaining for you guys
i had
[ __ ] blast oh there's 151 hi everyone
hope you are doing well from taco tommy
thank you taco tommy
no i'm gonna i gotta eat dinner uh
[Music]
but i'll be back with more streams
thanks for watching that was a blast
all right take care guys subscribe
check out merch take a shower
you know what i mean breakfast